[Musique]
bonjour à tous on se retrouve pour un
nouveau numéro du 7 8 dossiers avec une
édition un peu particulière pour faire
la transition avec l'année 2018 nous
avons voulu mettre en avant des
yvelinois qui ont marqué 2010 est ils
sont sportifs artistes chefs
d'entreprise ou bénévoles et à travers
leurs activités ils ont fait l'actualité
cette année les journalistes ont bien
sûr fait une sélection parmi plusieurs
personnes dans cette série de reportages
vous retrouverez notamment la montée en
nationale 3 de l'équipe de handball de
plaisir la performance des juniors de
l'association déclic de trappe lors des
championnats du monde d'un pro ou encore
lambert traîneau race fondateur de la
start up du giro lift qui a été
sélectionné pour le crs de lake las
vegas mais pour commencer nous avons
voulu mettre à l'honneur les bénévoles
des associations yvelinoise ils donnent
de leur temps pour aider les autres à
l'image de la croix rouge durant les
maraudes nous allons nous avons suivi
michel bernard engagé depuis plus de dix
ans regardez
[Musique]
un
train de préparer le matériel pour
nécessaire pour la maraude des produits
alimentaires des couvertures ou encore
des vêtements michel bernard prépare
aussi de l'eau chaude la base des
boissons destinées aux personnes sans
domicile un bien nécessaire en hiver
pour se réchauffer michel est bénévole à
la croix rouge il a rejoint
l'association en 2006 lorsqu'il prend sa
retraite ils commencent les maraudes
deux ans après voilà neuf ans qu'il est
engagé auprès des personnes dans le
besoin je pense que
jusque là on a su l'humanité pourquoi
pas essayer l'humanité
parce qu'on n'a pas sur celle aperçue
que l'inhumanité ça ne marche pas en
fait une pointe d'humour pour montrer un
engagement social allant de soi pour
michel ce soir il fait équipe avec amine
l'heure est au changement le vivent
là dessus
avant de partir michel contacter la
régulation du 115 ce service du samu
social directement en lien avec les
personnes sans abri oriente les
bénévoles sur le terrain on va jusqu'à
la mairie d'elancourt
visite de personnes qui sont
généralement sous le théâtre du prisme
mais je crois avoir une information
comme quoi ils ont été logés donc on va
quand même allé vérifier première
mission de la soirée à elancourt dans le
quartier 17 marc michel et amine vont
vérifier la situation de deux personnes
vivant sous l'escalier du prisme
finalement l'information de michel était
bonne les personnes ont été relogées par
la mairie d'elancourt là on a une
nouvelle mission donc on va voir nos
bénéficiaires qui est un peu un habitué
qui se trouve à l'église des sources
retour aux véhicules et direction
montigny le bretonneux pour porter
assistance à georges lors de la dernière
visite de michelle ce sans abri lui
avait demandé des vêtements les
bénévoles de la croix rouge vont lui
donner des shows sur un pull et de la
nourriture
on a beaucoup coulé on appelait la
crevette
georges a bénéficié d'une aide
vestimentaires et alimentaires
michel fait un bilan téléphonique à la
régulation avant de recevoir une
nouvelle mission une personne située à
saint cyr l'école il s'agit d'el feige
qui reçoit des produits alimentaires
mais pas seulement en plus d'une aide
sociale
inss z et puis il nous parle c'est
lorsqu'on n'a pas l'occasion de parler
honnêtement ses retranchements c'est
vrai c'est ils sont là quand même pour
nous donner un bon coup de main quoi
l'objectif de la maraude en elle-même en
fait c'est d'apporter une aide d'urgence
les gens appellent le 115
dans les quelques heures qui suivent ou
dans les premiers temps qui suivront
leur apporte le lait de plongeon de
monde après saint cyr l'école michel et
amine prennent la direction des essarts
le roi
la maraude ne fait que commencer elle va
durer jusqu'à minuit
[Musique]
une troisième édition qui couronne les
jeunes de trappes en avril dernier ils
deviennent champions du monde
d'improvisation junior face à eux les
québécois de se dire champion du monde
après cette francophone donc spam
mondial tout le monde mais ça que ça
fait vraiment plaisir
c'est un truc de ouf je me rappelle pas
tout les impros qu'on a fait toutes les
infos que j'ai fait mais moi j'ai joué
le match contre les avec les suisses et
le machrek et si c'était vraiment cool
le plus marquant pour moi c'était les
la vie à côté donc avec toutes les
équipes en dehors du de la scène
[Rires]
des rencontres avec d'autres junior
francophone pour ce troisième mondial la
suisse le québec et la belgique quatre
jours de compétition avec une soirée de
gala je retiendrai l'image du match des
étoiles ou ou en fait on a l'ensemble
des jeunes et des organisateurs qui
était sur le plateau il est pas une
image de faim peut retrouver sur
facebook quand je lis merci et les
coaches qui
travaillent au quotidien toute l'année
pour organiser entre autres ces mondiaux
la et
et qui ont dit leurs derniers mots
qui ont dit leurs mots voilà de salut de
remerciement au public trappistes une
victoire mondiale à l'image cette année
2010 est marquée par des rendez-vous un
riche en trophées on peut retenir que
c'est l'année où on a fait le plus de
spectacle cette année de toute
l'histoire de la compagnie donc ça ça
reste quelque chose d'assez important
l'équipe de trappes intercollèges a
remporté le trophée culture et diversité
et que le site mythe a été remporté par
un collège de trappes et que en plus
cerise sur le gâteau les épices les
adultes amateurs ont rapporté la baston
jovial qui est un tournoi parisien voilà
donc pour nous c'est une année assez
assez complète à plusieurs niveaux si
l'année 2010 cette touche à sa fin la
saison culturelle de la compagnie
continue avec un rendez vous immanquable
le mondial d'impro junior en avril il
faudra faire ses valises direction le
québec
[Musique]
c'est dans ce laboratoire de l'ue vs qu
à vélizy que lambert très nora a conçu
le giro lift ce jeune ingénieur de 28
ans est titulaire d'un master
mécatronique et d'un doctorat en
robotique cette nouvelle solution de
mobilité est basé sur un gyropode un
concept unique au monde donc à l'origine
je réussis était un projet de recherche
et et puis au fur et à mesure de son
développement on s'est dit mais pourquoi
pas le muet en projet entrepreneurial
actuellement il existait des solutions
seulement à six mais nous on permet
aussi de se déplacer deux bouts avec des
fonctionnalités de sécurisation
intelligentes etc et et ça quel point
important c'est qu'on l'offre à tous
types d'usagés que ce soit de la
personne valide à la personne en
situation de handicap en mobilité
réduite
encore à l'état de prototype le giro
lift a pourtant déjà remporté de
nombreux prix mais celui-ci obtenu le 21
septembre dernier et la consécration
pour le jeune entrepreneur il s'agit du
prix du public lors de la finale du
challenge paris saclay c es 2018 un
concours organisé par la cci des
yvelines qui lui offre son ticket pour
le salon high-tech de las vegas c'est un
peu la mecque des nouvelles technologies
on s'est toujours dit c'était toujours
une boutade au sein de l'équipe en
disant à l'année prochaine on ira où
si on présente là-bas c'est la
consécration
lambert très n'aura aura trois jours
pour mettre en avant le savoir faire
français et plus particulièrement le
savoir-faire yvelinois il espère que ce
rendez vous mondial sera un véritable
tremplin pour son avenir si on peut
signer des partenariats des contrats
avec un marché nord-américain c'est
toujours face est pour ça qu on y va
puis après c'est vrai que c'est le lieu
aussi pour rencontrer des décideurs même
des décideurs français zarco des les
patrons de grands groupes français de
décideurs français vont s es pour voir
ce qui se fait donc en fait c'était pas
plus tard que la semaine dernière je
discute avec une start up qui est allé
et il m'a dit si tu veux rencontrer les
personnages des français est important
il faut que tu ailles là bas une année
2010 est qui va peut-être permettre à
lamberth renora de vivre son rêve
américain
objectif pour 2018 commercialiser son
giro lift au second semestre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
2010cette année de la consécration pour
le plaisir handball club après avoir
lutté pour la montée pendant six ans les
plaisirs ont enfin validé leur ticket
pour la nationale 3 en mai dernier en
s'imposant contre draveil à domicile
l'équipe termine première du classement
avec une seule défaite au compteur donc
je pense que ça représente énormément
pour le public pour le club les anciens
du club le tout les dirigeants les
bénévoles les petits enfin c'est
vraiment une grande famille c'est pour
tout le monde voilà c'est pas que nous
c'est pas que les doux c'est vraiment un
club qu'avec tout ce moment là tous
ensemble après l'euphorie retour sur
terre plaisir se mesurer pour la
première fois une équipe de nationale 3
en coupe de france début septembre après
un match serré les plaisirs oies sont
finalement éliminé par le club d'ici aux
tirs au but le score 28 à 27 une défaite
formatrice pour le groupe une équipe
réellement le profil des équipes de
nationale 3 à savoir des joueurs avec un
petit peu tous les profils et notamment
des grands gabarits qui sont capables
d'aller jouer des duels et ces
choses qu'on trouve très peu en
prénationale donc voila c'était très
intéressant de cette équipe
avec voilà nos qualités aujourd'hui
après quatre mois de compétition plaisir
pointe à la deuxième place du
championnat de nationale 3 3 longueurs
du leader saint polois les événements
notamment réalisé une série de quatre
victoires consécutives entre octobre et
novembre l'équipe a été remaniée puisque
effectivement on a perdu quelques
joueurs
le fait d'avoir dressé quelques joueurs
n'ont pas changé à l'état d'esprit du
groupe l'état d'esprit est toujours
positif les mecs s'entraîne sérieusement
on s'entraîne sérieusement et donc cette
deuxième place au championnat je pense
qu'elle est méritée maintenant on sait
que ça va être dur de la garder ma nous
battre et continuer sur cet état
d'esprit qui est pour l'instant est
repproché avec cette bande de potes
malgré cette place de dauphin l'objectif
annoncé de cette saison 2017-2018 reste
le maintien la montée pour le moment une
question taboue écoutez se passe on peut
parler de monter certains vous diront
peut-être que j'y pense moi aujourd'hui
déjà on prend chaque match et le groupe
prend chaque match l'un après les autres
avec l'objectif est effectivement de les
gagner très belle année 2010 est et
espérons que l'année 2008 a le même but
he plaisir prendra officiellement la
compétition le 27 janvier prochain
l'extérieur contre chaville une victoire
et les plaisirs wa deviendraient encore
un peu plus l'équipe à suivre en 2018
dans ce championnat
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce sept huit dossiers
merci de nous avoir suivis je vous
souhaite mes meilleurs voeux pour cette
année 2010 8 vous pouvez nous retrouver
sur notre application mobile ou sur le
site internet de télé 78 à bientôt pour
l'ouverture d'un nouveau dossier
[Musique]